Good morning John. Today, we are going to
be making cinnamon toast two different ways.
First way. [Happy ska montage music]
Mmmmm. The butter and the cinnamon and sugar
creates this like crust on the top that is
hard and the bread is soggy underneath. That
is good stuff. This one's good.
This is what we call the soggy technique:
butter first, then toaster. Now we're going
to try the crunchy technique. [Heavy guitar
montage music]
I'm not even gonna put this in my mouth! Team
soggy for life!
If you're confused right now, that's kind
of the point. I just posted something on Tumblr
about the way that I make cinnamon toast,
and people criticized me for it, saying that
you should toast before you butter which is
ludicrous!
There was something of a debate. People died.
I mean, people did die, in the world, while
we were having the debate, but not actually
because of the debate.
Though I don't know. Team soggy, team crunchy,
there's a lot of animosity there. I know I
harbor some for those team crunchies out there.
I don't know what they're thinking!
It may be that I'm projecting other stress
onto this situation though. I mean I don't
know what could possibly go aaarrrgggwwwwaaahh.
It's a metaphor! You put the killing thing
between your teeth, but you don't let it kill
Do you think that poster's worth more or less
now that I've chewed on it? We just released
the agenda. Like, what's happening at what
times during VidCon two thousand and, what
is it? 2014 right now? I don't know.
I also discovered during this process that
there are places where toaster ovens don't
exist. It's like a tiny oven where you just
toast.
For people who only have toasters, I understand
why you do team crunchy; it's a limitation
of your situation. That's fine. You can however,
broil in the actual oven, if you have one
of those. It's just so much better. It's so...
it's so much better.
We do a charity auction at VidCon, and I actually
need to go paint some anglerfish art for that
auction so, bwaah!
I'm painting art for the VidCon auction. Problem
is, I don't know how to do that. [Katherine
laughs]
Turned out okay. I only said I would do two;
I did four.
Housekeeping! Tank tops will be on sale until
Monday. So if you want get a tank top, the
pre-order only lasts till Monday, then we
may bring them back we may not depending on
how they sell.
And if you haven't heard about this or have
been postponing your ticket purchasing - Tour
Because Awesome! With Hank Green and the Perfect
Strangers and Harry and the Potters and Driftless
Pony Club and Andrew Huang and Rob Scallon,
all amazing musicians. We are going to have
a blast.
And I hope that you're going to be there to
have a blast with us. Uh, there's a link in
the description if you want to get tickets,
they're like fifteen to twenty dollars.
Ugh. You wanna know something funny? When
I get really stressed out my defense mechanism
is to get really sleepy. How to avoid stress?
I know! Unconsciousness. It's great! I would
totally rather that than just laying there
in bed thinking about stuff. I just, when
I get stressed out like a light bulb I go
out.
Like a light bulb with a hole drilled in the
side of it. They go out extra fast because
there's oxygen in the chamber. There needs
to be a vacuum, so that the filament doesn't
burn. Yeah, sometimes it's just better to
not... better to not.
Comments: Team soggy or team crunchy? Is that
poster worth more now or less now?
Thanks to Michael Aranda for help with this
video. Thanks to everybody for their help
with VidCon. And John, I'll see you on Tuesday.